hello i'm a citizen and i'm the
government and i'm really excited
because it's election season
and we've narrowed it down to the two
best candidates i don't really like
either of those candidates can i see
some independent candidates
oh no they didn't get enough signatures
to get on the ballot this year
but the two main people got enough
signatures to get on the ballot
no no no they don't need signatures the
two main parties are automatically on
the ballot
because they get the most votes every
election exactly
because they're automatically on the
ballot oh the debate's about to start
i can't wait these are the two best
candidates available
there's nobody else better
nobody hello i'm a citizen
and i'm the government there is a cat
stuck in a tree
i'll call the police okay uh i just saw
a fender bender
i'll call the police and there's a
homeless lady looks like she needs to
call the police
in a parade coming by police school hall
monitor police
you know what i i'm gonna go join that
protest about excessive reliance on
police oh
i may get to call the military on this
one
hello i'm a citizen and i'm the
government my nephew just turned 18.
oh that's great to celebrate he can sign
up to go to war
uh what yeah when a guy turns 18 they
have to sign up to go to
a foreign country and kill people with
automatic weapons
[Music]
okay yeah or i thought we could
celebrate by having a beer
uh no no no that is illegal
he's just a kid come on man you break
that law
and we will prosecute him as an adult
we've prosecuted ten-year-olds as adults
before